the top story this afternoon more
injuries for the star-crossed san
francisco 49ers
look last year it was not easy for them
to get near the top of the mountain they
had to fight and scratch and claw all
the way to week 17. yes they had a
special season there were no gimmies
along the way there were a few blowouts
they had to deal with the seahawks they
had to deal with the rams they had to
deal with the cardinals they had to deal
with teams like the vikings and packers
in the playoffs and ultimately couldn't
overcome the chiefs this year they can't
overcome the injuries george kittle star
tight end out eight weeks with a broken
bone in his foot that happened yesterday
in the loss to the seattle seahawks and
jimmy garoppolo
high ankle sprain again
out at least a month this time
the 49ers
and this is stunning
and maybe this will help the 49ers in
deciding what to do at the quarterback
position after this year
they're 24 and 9
in games that jimmy garoppolo starts
and five and 21 when someone else starts
since uh the 2017 season that's stunning
to me
it's very stunning mike and
it feels like like i was looking up nick
mullen's record while ago it feels like
he's better than what he is he's four
and six he went one and one this year
but it just seems like he's played
better than that but obviously he hasn't
and the 49ers can't seem to win without
jimmy g and you know whatever they do
with the quarterback position whether
it's jimmy or somebody else after this
season it certainly doesn't need to be
one of these backups they're not the
same team when it's nick mullins or cj
beathard in the lineup but you know you
do wonder mike if the 49ers put jimmy
garoppolo back in the lineup too soon
after the heinkel sprain the first time
he played through it in the jets game
missed a couple games came back in that
week five game it was obvious against
the dolphins he shouldn't have been
playing and then the next week he looked
right again so they probably put him out
there too quick did that lead to lip to
this it does make you wonder whether
they should have kept him out longer let
that thing fully heal and now here we
are again maybe it wouldn't have made a
difference who knows but you do wonder
that with what he's going through now
but this is just it seemed like almost a
daily occurrence for the 49ers one
injury after another injury and i don't
know how you get through all these
injuries and and make the playoffs and
and they've talked about
getting back as nfc champions they
talked about that since the point in the
super bowl last year and now here we are
they're gonna have a tough time doing
that with all these injuries
i think the analysis when it comes to
garoppolo and his injury was fairly
simple they balanced an impaired
garoppolo against a healthy
nick mullins or a healthy cj beathard
and they decided to roll the dice with
an injured jimmy garoppolo it didn't
work against the miami dolphins it did
work after that in the wins over the
rams and the new england patriots and
back to nick mullins look he was
adequate against the jets when he came
in when garoppolo was injured the first
time he beat the giants the next week
and then there was that game against the
eagles where you know he throws the ball
to the other team as if he's playing for
the eagles that night and that caused
him to fall to number three on the depth
chart and at some point in the past
couple of weeks the 49ers decided to go
week by week deciding which of the two
backups would be the number two guy
depending upon the match up and it
wasn't a competition between the two
some weeks kyle shanahan thought it
would be better for beathard other weeks
better for mullins remains to be seen
who gets the start on thursday night
against the green bay packers though
mullins is the one who came in on sunday
but garoppolo now you have to wonder
number one will they have him beyond
this season number two we'll even play
again this season because if this goes
downhill for them and remember there's
still only three games into the seven
game death march if this goes downhill
for them
maybe they just decide not to put him
back on the field maybe they decide to
just let that ankle heal completely and
entirely so
when the time comes to try to trade him
in the offseason shireen he's not still
recovering from any type of injury he's
100
when march rolls around he's got two
years left on his contract salaries of
24.1 million next year 24.2 million the
year after that i won't be surprised if
they try to trade him they may not be
able to find any takers maybe they have
to pay some of the salary to get him off
the books but regardless the way it's
going now i don't think he'll be back
next year they'll look at their options
and there's the schedule
for the next four weeks while garoppolo
is out packers at saints at rams bills
it doesn't soften up until after that
with washington and the cowboys and then
they finish strong
from an opponent's standpoint against
the cardinals in the seahawks so it
feels like the beginning of the end
frankly for jimmy garoppolo in san
francisco
the good thing for them mike and why
they may bring him back is ultimately
they're going to get most of these
players back i realize nick bose is not
coming back who you really need as a
pass rusher but they're going to get a
lot of these guys back you figure
kittles will be healthy enough by the
end of the year to come back debo samuel
is going to miss another game but he'll
be back if you get all those guys back
this is not a team i would want to play
in the playoffs so if they can get
healthy and actually make the plows even
if they get that last extra playoff spot
as a wild card team
it's not a team i want to face because
they have all this playoff experience
they were really good last year and and
you hope that they are they hope at that
point that they're really healthy and
can win a playoff game so that's the
only thing i think the extra wild card
team and the fact that they could get
healthy by the end of the year
could bring all these guys back and
maybe they think by playoff time we're
really rolling and we're starting to
play well again but other than that i
mean the next few games are going to
determine to me they have to beat the
rams that's that that is a must-win game
for them on that schedule when you start
looking at possible w's and l's i think
they have to win that game they start
losing a bunch of these games then yeah
it's not worth bringing any of these
guys back for this season i mean let's
be realistic about where they've
struggled this year they've
they beat the rams the first time but
they lost to the seahawks they lost to
the cardinals they play both of them
again i just think it's going to be very
difficult for them to position
themselves
for
a playoff spot when you consider they're
in last place at four and four
and and i i think that seahawks
cardinals rams will have a good chance
to get there
but either the saints or the buccaneers
will be getting one of those wild card
spots i don't see the 49ers catching new
orleans or san francisco they've got a
game coming up against new orleans that
will be critical see what the 49ers need
to hope for is that
they their separation
in the nfc south and the second place
team starts to fade so they can maybe be
picked off by the 49ers that's
unless they're going to leapfrog the
rams
or the cardinals their best shot is to
hope that the second place team in the
nfc south fades away because look the
bears are starting to free fall there
isn't going to be a second place team
from the nfc east that is in contention
it's too late for the vikings at two and
five i think to get into the playoff
hunt the 49ers number one they're going
to need to win and number two they need
to start
thinking about not that they will i mean
somebody in the organization perak
marathi or someone will have it all
figured out all the different
permutations and ways to get in all they
can take care of is winning games but
that they
you know yeah if they were on the table
they won't have a problem at 12 and four
but we've seen them without these help
without their key players we've seen
what it looks like my only hesitation is
every time it feels like they're down
kyle shanahan finds a way to spring them
back to life and every time you give up
on the 49ers they rip off a couple of
wins and look great and then you start
buying into it and then it goes the
other way
yeah that's exactly right mike and
that's what's happened this whole year
to them and and it has been just one
entry after another we talked about the
running back depth
last week because they had all the
running backs who were injured and now
it's the quarterback again and then it's
the tight end and eventually you run out
of guys i mean they to me have been the
most injury plug team and i know the
cowboys and the broncos have had injury
issues but really when you look at the
49ers there's just been one guy after
another and and some of them are season
ending and i just don't eventually you
just can't overcome all those injuries
and
let's face it a lot in this league has
to do with availability and who has the
healthiest team and this year with kovid
thrown in there who doesn't get coveted
who doesn't have the issues and right
now it's the steelers who who've been
the healthiest and done all the right
things and and so far that's why they're
they're the lone undefeated team there
have been others but they have been
truly healthy this year for the most
part and i think that's really played a
big part in where they are
and the 49ers could draw a lucky card on
thursday night as it relates to covet
because the packers have an issue that
is still emerging and who knows whether
they'll even be able to play this game
on thursday night we'll talk about that
coming up one last thing about the 49ers
and keep this in mind in march they
evaluated the possibility of signing tom
brady they were very transparent about
it they told jimmy garoppolo they talked
publicly about it but what that was was
a shot across the ballot jimmy garoppolo
it was a you better step up or you're
going to be stepping off and i think
they are going to evaluate all options
all opportunities some have suggested a
matt ryan jimmy garoppolo reunion in san
francisco others like me have said maybe
that's where kirk cousins will end up
that's the guy that garoppolo or that
shanahan thought he was going to get
three years ago when they traded for
garoppolo right around the trade
deadline so
i think all options are on the table for
the 49ers at the quarterback position
next year as they try to reload on the
fly
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports